I don't know how you feel about this but
you and I are both people that
I get my energy the way a plant needs
the sun I need an audience to kind of be
letting me know what's happening and uh
and and so I never uh did anything in
film and was never never something I
even thought about and then I had this
experience last summer where I shot
something and
I found myself
it's such a different pace you know all
right come to set you wait around and
then it's your time to go and you do
something and you're wondering was that
funny uh and then you they tried a bunch
of different times from a million
different angles and then it's go wait
some more and I thought yeah I don't
know if this is my
milieu yeah I don't know if this is my
because I I'm so reliant on getting into
the flow with people and feeling it and
this idea of doing it almost surgically
in a sound stage and then we'll let you
know in a year yeah how this turned out
yeah is very strange but fascinating
it's really fascinating I'm like you bro
you need like validation that you're
what you're doing is funny you know like
I I found myself in some of these scenes
like cut and I'm looking around going
nothing you know like uh
you know like and they're just they're
working their equipment they're not yeah
yeah what guys what someone die no we're
checking levels and what are you talking
about well even you see those like
bloopers or or whatever like Jim
Carrey's doing like uh something or or
Will Ferrell's doing something and then
the camera guys she's like it's shaking
the camera right I'm looking for those
moments right nothing I'm getting any of
this no one's shaking
so I you have to almost have like a
feeling that this is this is I guess
funny I guess I guess this is funny I
don't know I mean I had a different
experience on the TV show where
uh I just did with Chuck Lloyd Chuck
Lori you could actually hear him
laughing right in the background right
so you go oh okay then you know some
making one guy laugh
uh but yeah this uh the the movie was uh
silence yeah so we're looking uh forward
to seeing I mean listen when we when we
viewed it in a theater you know people
were laughing but it's just not not
during the process right but it's such a
different thing too is the time lag also
I'm sure you were heavily involved in
editing and you know were you allowed to
be in there that was a lot I went in
there I didn't I didn't like dig deep
into the editing there was moments I go
I think there was a better take and we
we looked at that but I was like not the
whole like day in day out editing of a
film I wasn't heavily involved in that
no yeah my experiences whenever I say
what about that other take that was
really funny guys will just look at me
and go yeah we looked at it it's not
funny
and then I just my penis retracts up
into my body
it takes months to lure it back out
again put out little crackers and stuff
for it
a 1980s play Playboy Adrian Barbeau
nothing I said too much Summer's Here of
course summer is the time for everything
fresh let me list a few fresh air
refreshing vacations and plenty of
hellofresh to 11 up Meals that's where I
was going hello fresh and with Chef
crafted seasonal recipes and new fresh
and fit summer menu hellofresh brings
you flavor right to your door yeah now's
the peak time for summer produce hello
fresh make sure you get all the best
picks all season long delicious fresh
meals mmm we'll make your home the place
to be this summer pre-proportioned
ingredients that help cut down on food
waste and time while step-by-step
Instructions make cooking a breeze not a
chore hello fresh combines quality and
convenience with ingredients making it
from the farm to your door in less than
seven days Sona hello fresh saved your
life I don't know if it saved my life as
a cook you're a disaster on your own but
when Hello fresh is involved it's
fantastic I didn't think that was the
case but yeah I really like hello fresh
they sent me three meals one was a
chicken one was a pork and one was a
fish yeah and fantastic I crushed it
yeah and I'm remember going to your
house once for dinner before you use
hellofresh and you serve me one meatball
on an ice cream cone yeah no that's not
a meal but hello fresh did is it totally
upped your game congratulations Sona
that was a good meatball uh now I'm not
sure that was meat anyway
go to hellofresh.com Team coco50 and use
code Team Coco 50 for 50 off plus free
shipping that's team coco50
hellofresh.com team coco50 for 50 off
plus free shipping America's number one
meal kit I could talk to you forever I
I've uh I I'm a big fan of your work uh
you really make me laugh but I also
appreciate
that you're a uh you are a very
thoughtful uh guy and you are someone
who has taken his career really
seriously and made it all happen through
sheer force of will and a ton of talent
but
you've put a lot of work into what
you've done and I I hope that you are
able to find moments
of relaxation and and that's that's I
think what there's no such thing as I
want to get to the point where I'm just
blissfully happy all the time because
that means you've had a neurological
accident you know yeah but what you're
look what I'm hoping for is that you get
better and better at finding moments
where you say
Jesus Christ look what I've look what
I've done yeah and
enjoy and say yeah I'm gonna get the
biggest lobster they have here
without the coupon
hey Sebastian thank you uh so much for
being here and uh I'm excited for about
my father I think that's so cool thank
you and one more thing before we leave
yeah after we take the headphones off
and we're gonna do this and then oh yeah
that was fun guys yeah
um
get your number
look you just
you just crossed you just crossed a lot
you just crossed the line and what if
you just said that in four security
guards walk in quietly
yes you will get my number okay you will
get my number and then we gotta get wine
at some point yeah no we we have a lot
of parties at the house small nice nice
group of people you come up and uh I'm
gonna be um loud and jokey even if I
don't feel it even if I don't feel like
this the mood is right if someone's up
there talking about a disease they just
got diagnosed with I'm still gonna go
for it I think these are all children's
birthday parties
crap
I killed those things I kill
all right well thank you very much you
got it it's great thanks thanks for
having me